les collections prêt à porter automne
hiver 2002 2003 avec aujourd'hui le
défilé dior dessinée par john galliano a
parfaitement sur les podiums estelle
colada david fossard objet de toutes les
convoitises même collés les uns aux
autres personne n'aurait raté l'un des
plus fameux rendez vous de la semaine
des collections depuis cinq ans
maintenant c'est lui qui donne le ton de
la saison tu jouais juste briquet
j'allume le ferait après ça court quand
comme ça se gagne et non ce n'est pas
seulement le fou de dior c'est aussi
celui qui a su révolutionner l'une des
plus grandes institutions du luxe
l'homme a du talent il son inspiration
lui vient de loin j'ai encore booster
pour la maison de monsieur diot je suis
très honnête avec moi et qu'est ce que
je fais ici et et je crois que ce que je
fais c'est vraiment dans l'esprit de
monsieur dior présente chacune de ses
créations se transforme en chiffre
d'affaires des chiffres de vente par
rami lui qui ne cesse de croître + 50%
ces deux derniers mois d'après les
sources de l'amusement
je le dis il faut parler de le chiffre
d'affaires d'aujourd'hui dans la maison
dior
il faut voir de plus en plus nombreuses
nouvelles clientes qui sont chez dior il
faut voir où est dit on aujourd'hui
pour moi ça c'est la preuve l'incroyable
john a donc décidé qu'il y aurait
beaucoup de soleil l'hiver prochain lui
a choisi d'affronter son public
timidement avec la sobriété d'un simple
costume noir